what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some outstanding news today
when it comes to the strikes the wga and
the studios and streaming services have
reached an agreement finally we have a
lot of details about what happened on
Saturday and Sunday and of course we'll
talk about everything that we know so
far another big thing is that the
picketing has stopped outside of the
studios right now the wga has called for
an end to the picketing of course that
comes with this new deal between the wga
and the studios and fortunately for
everybody they have agreed to a final
deal that is apparently very good for
the wga the writers are getting a good
deal now this is not the end of both
strikes the actor strikes are still
happening that's the SAG after strike
that is still going on but once the
rider strike gets cleared up the actors
are next and it seems like both sides
the writers and the Studios have been
pretty reasonable it sounds like this
deal is pretty good the writers are
happy with it so let's break down what
we know about what happened over the
weekend in the meetings between the two
different sides the studios and the
writers and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe to the channel so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items we pick one winner at
the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item we only have five
days left so be sure to enter so the two
sides have agreed on a deal however it
does need to be finalized basically what
that means is they have to draw up the
final contracts the lawyers have to look
over them and then each party has to
sign now they have already agreed on the
deals both side have and they both have
released statements together stating
they have reached a deal so it is
official they have come to the
conclusion that the deal that they put
on the table Sunday night last night is
acceptable for both sides and actually
the wga released this statement it we
can say with great pride that this deal
is exceptional with meaningful gains and
protections for writers in every sector
of the membership so that's awesome The
Writer's Guild is clearly happy with
what they are getting in this new deal
and this is a big deal because this was
a historic strike it lasted
146 days here's what The Hollywood
Reporter had to say about this after
several long consecutive days of
negotiations The Writer's Guild of
America and the labor group representing
the studios and streamers have reached a
tentative deal on a new contract and a
major development that could precipitate
the end of a historic 146 Day Rider
strike the writer's Guild of America
emailed the strike captains the news on
Sunday night and shortly after its
negotiating committee and informed all
the members and they stated and I quote
we have reached a tentative agreement on
a new 2023 MBA which is to say an
agreement in principle on all deal
points subject to drafting final
contract language and then they also
stated again we can say with great pride
that this deal is exceptional with
meaningful gains and protections for
writers in every sector of the
membership and this was all stated in an
email that the wga emailed the strike
captains in the negotiating committee
and like I mentioned the alliance of
motion picture and television producers
confirmed this news in a joint statement
with the wga about the deal on Sunday so
this has been confirmed by both sides
it's not just one side stating hey we
think we got a deal no it is both sides
of green yes we have a deal now let's
drop the paperwork and finalize it as
far as what we know about what took
place on Sunday and Saturday this is
what The Hollywood Reporter stated the
parties came to terms on a provisional
three-year agreement which will need to
be ratified by wga members to take
effect on Sunday after Studios responded
to last minute Union asked that day
specifics of the deal affecting around
eleven thousand five 100 at wja members
weren't available as of press time
though they will emerge in the next few
days and here's what they had to say
about why all of that information is not
released yet and keep in mind they have
not revealed this to the members yet so
it's not that it hasn't been revealed to
the public yet they literally haven't
shared it with the members of the wga
yet here's what they said in its message
to members the unions negotiating
committee asked for patience on
disclosing the fine print of the deal
and they stated and I quote what remains
now is for our staff to make sure
everything we have agreed to is codified
in final contract language and though we
are eager to share the details of what
has been achieved with you we cannot do
that until the last I is dotted this
obviously makes sense the lawyers have
not completed the final contracts on
each side is not signed the final
contract and until they do that they
don't want to share anything they want
to make sure it's done first they don't
want to get the hopes up of everybody
even though they have agreed to a deal
both sides have they have both publicly
stated together in a joint statement
that they have come to a deal and that
the strikes are over the wga has even
called for the picketing to stop so no
more picketing outside of Studios this
is all but done both sides have agreed
but they have to dot the eyes and they
have to officially sign that's when it
goes into effect and that is what
everybody is waiting for once that
happens then everything can be disclosed
so here's what happens now the deal will
first go to the Union's negotiating
committee for a vote then to the wga
West Sport and the wga East Council for
approval both referendums are
tentatively scheduled for Tuesday
tomorrow if rubber stamped by those
leaders board and Council will also vote
on whether to end the strike once these
leadership votes have taken place
members will receive a summary of the
agreement and a memorandum of the
agreement prior to their own
ratification vote in the meantime the
wga has suspended ticketing while
reminding members that no one is to
return to work until the union gives the
green light so basically what has to
happen now is all of the legal
requirements both sides have agreed
again they issued a joint statement it's
out there in the public everybody knows
but now they have to go through the
legal steps so the members of the wga
the leadership they're gonna vote it's
gonna pass because again they've already
agreed to it and they've already
released a statement that says that the
New Deal is quite exceptional and it's
very good for them so they're going to
accept it in the vote from there on out
the final contract between the two sides
gets signed and then the details of the
deal what everything is exactly will get
released to the members and of course
the public so this is all apparently
happening on Tuesday so hopefully it'll
all be officially done this week because
now that the writer strike is over it's
time to move on to the actor strike when
it comes to the movie TV and streaming
Studios this has all affected them
greatly this is definitely affected
Marvel Studios we've already had a few
pushbacks and release dates and projects
have been put on hold due to these
strikes Deadpool 3 is a big one it was
right in the middle of filming and
filming and production for it got shut
down this was a big deal for Ryan
Reynolds because a lot of what he does
is riding on the spot with his improv so
that was a big hit to Deadpool and then
of course when the actor strike started
everything just got shut down so this is
great news today that the rider strikes
are over because now they can get back
to at least riding the rest of the phase
5 and Phase 6 projects Marvel Studios
can also hire Riders now which has been
a big thing recently a lot of rumors
going around about Avengers Kang Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars getting New
Riders and we've heard a lot of inside
information about it however Marvel
Studios couldn't officially do anything
because of the strikes so now they can
do that they can get the ball rolling
for the riders for all of these projects
so hopefully now that this is done the
actor strikes will be worked on very
very soon hopefully immediately after
the writer strikes officially end so as
far as the actor strikes are concerned
they are still going to be picketing for
the actor strikes outside of Studio is
and the actors still won't be able to
film so as far as delays for Marvel
Studios goes they're still going to be
delayed unfortunately Deadpool 3 won't
pick up again until the actor strikes
are done but the good news is now that
the writer strike is over the delay
won't be as much because now the Riders
can continue to work on these scripts
that way they are done and ready for the
actors to begin working on win the
strike for the actors finally does
finish if the rider strike would
continue to go on and end at the same
time as the actor strike then the
writers wouldn't have had time to finish
the scripts beforehand so overall for
both sides this is great news it's a
great win for the wga and now the delays
for everything on the studios aside
they'll stop or at least dramatically be
decreased until the actor strikes are
over as well and the fact that they have
negotiated with the wga is really really
good news and it should mean that the
SAG after should be getting a pretty
decent deal hopefully as well pretty
soon but go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about this awesome news in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video video And subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf